ciao ragazzi sono in pura puro assetto
giapponese con tanto di trucco che mi
sta riprendendo anche il sedere e volevo
dirvi ragazzi che il 29 settembre
venerdì sarò a milano games week e ciao
ciao casa base
e anche lei a crisi presso il mit
village mentre domenica 1º ottobre sarò
sempre al games week
allo stand di intesa sanpaolo e
siccome domenica farò anche delle storie
le parole di al profilo di intesa
sanpaolo giovani quindi seguite sui
propri giovani che i giovani tutti su
instagram
non sono capace di dire le cose a
distinguere i social e la troupe è
rimasta indietro però mi sta sempre
riprendendo c'è il fonico che saluta
assoluto anche poi ci vediamo è buono e
gianni bella tutti ragazzi è benvenuta
questo nuovo video sono fa vj e oggi
sono su rocket league che la donna
vitale non facciamo un video sul rocker
e sono con l'ineguagliabile ciccio gamer
fiori e lo zio
salve a tutti non pensavo che facesse un
2 v 2 e quindi adesso l'ansia da
prestazione
ma perché pensa pensa che facessimo 1
contro 1 art 1 pensavo sempre di 332 a
noi tre ti dirò di più stiamo giocando
in classificata nell'arte tanto non sono
andato in 22 quindi ce la possiamo fare
galati run chiama subito al bravo
ragazzo ma io sto un po in difesa per
quella non è una difesa non era difesa
all'aspettativa che prova andare in a
tra gli stai dentro mai dentro alcuna
questo qua si sposti dicendo mi dispiace
era partita la dobbiamo finire 4 1 per
noi ti va bene 51 so ancora più provata
nel primo e queste aspetta che stavolta
fanno noi
dai dai dai
dentro c dentro ha dentro occhio che se
ti saltano che è grigia occhio però
benissimo
bravo trova benissimo bike avanzo
bravissimo va bene così ora lo stop e
vedo se scappare una roba bella e modo
ma c'era un casino in iraq e no no no
non ci posso non ci posso credere
dai ragazzi adesso che l'ha recuperata
questo dovrebbe essere gol sono uno
sfiga sostiene porca vacca che partita
brutta o possiamo perderlo a zero la
prima tagliatogli la va bene lo stesso
possibile ma non possiamo essere così
non è possibile
vai via da qui tu no la sorren diamo
basta una fitta e alla fatta cosmetiche
ma abbiamo fatto questa partita inizia
lì inizia ora adesso bene a tutti i
ragazzi
benvenuti a questo video di roche clic
sul serio convinto che oggi faremo del
nostro meglio per portare a casa un
risultato
egregio critiche di noi che che vinciamo
sempre a questo giorno prima partita è
il bar prima non abbiamo ancora fatto e
chissà come va a finire questa vai vai
carico bravo medici acqua pure questo
milan è prima partenza e pinta ciccio
bravo intimoriti questi ragazzi ecco il
nostro file o perché non so stufa ti
preoccupare
oggi tocca la bravissima
non ci crede in due a palermo ragazzi ci
stiamo concentrando in un modo o ciò
vada oggi è presa donnarumma non pensava
il trash ha fatto la cappellata di becca
un portiere prima partita i ragazzi in
crediti sottolinea incredibile la
partita madonna che intesa rai 3 a 0 e
con su youtube si domina che andiamo a
fare italiane e internazionali mondiali
perfetto bravissimo
ancora un gol in genere su rendono gli
altri quando fanno il 40 occhio che
questa è buona o di queste cuore a me lo
sento di c un no non ancora rimasta lì è
ottimista riprende il mantova se la
prende viti chiamo buffon regalati così
non so che sarà veramente impossibile
bravo minuto resistiamo
no e non è mio padre ci credo non ci
posso credere o no bike no vabbè laroni
non importa 31 a bastone non prendiamo
con 13 secondi non di super difensivo
l'oramai fi
mamma mia ok bravissimo rimani rimane in
difesa 10 secondi la pelliccia la lascia
lì
praticamente si era perfetto una novità
bravi non possono confermare la prima
andata ragazzi oggi vi vogliamo tre su
tre la prima è andata
che bello e venire ma dov'è entrato
hanno segnato loro non hanno segnato
perché stupido e subito
vai vai vada presa perdere loro che
siamo a banana spiedo e no punta butta
là va bene bravo ok perfetto va lì e
pensi agli agenti bellissimo insieme è
stato stupendo bellissimo la potenza
degli iscritti tutte in faccia
bellissimo occhio bene alle 21 su bravo
bravo ormai campioni del mondo si stanno
inquinando i 33 rarissimo il mio
compagno è nato fatto va bene così sono
mais o no bene delle versioni mezzo
buona l'elemento ancora emma 44 mesi
diciamo che era l'ho passata al treno
che passa temi opera guardano ora e
mezzo adatto a cosa che cosa stava
venendo beccarmi ci siamo non dovrei
fare io
oggi no che vola via madonna si parlava
domanda sul fenomeno
siamo diventati forti tira tira tira
tira dietro ci arrivò mai l'ha buttata
via
ti sfido io se entrava così mi devo fino
ad ora pero tina faccio no agi tutta a
buttare madonna che bella che se io
sapessi giocare sarebbe meglio è molto
buona questo è molto buona occhio che
spizzica è bravo
pensavo entrasse già di tuo ma ottimo
anzi no no perfetto
raga un 3 a 0 direi che come seconda
partita e merita free no ma qua
veramente ma veramente sarebbe vista mi
sa che non sono andato perché non gli
porti bravo ciccio direi che come
l'ultima partita possiamo fare la
differenza ovviamente due su due
batterie c'è due senza il tre su treno
effetto ma allora facciamoli subito
vedere chi comanda si stanno tutti si
siedono per terra e vai vai mai così
azioni da faccio il dj grande errore
vai sempre dire stai bene vai vai carica
carica la voce ma per bravissimo
bravissimo ei no problem invece è invece
che sta il problema io sapessi giocare
non ci stava ma è 1 a 1 ma secondo me
possiamo fatto o no ma pensiamo che la
facciamo
grazie dio madonna che gol bellissimo
mai spinto su una palla che si è spinto
sulla palla e stato bellissimo inducendo
dentro con la palla va a letto tutto
calcolato
mi son tattiche bye bye bye nello
ribassi morte morte
no no va benissimo perché ottenuta che
cosa è qui è stato stupendo live
attrazione incredibile senza volerlo
andata bene guardava pallonetto ragazzi
ma prende marco donnarumma le fumate che
stiamo farla scusate perfetto ai così
spera solo voi avete chi sei e marco e
vabbè è infatti tagliarci i ragazzi po
più esigui madonna
[Musica]
ho mollato joystick per farti la plata
mente cosa hai preso ma non ho mai visto
la parata del genere arrivo speck e
stavo giocando ad aia manca un minutino
è secondo me un altro gol e lo picchia
maradona ma mette mai arbitro testa
rapido gol che ho segnato io non è
possibile perché l'ultimo dopo le foto 2
all'ultimo tocco è stato nergia macron e
come successo ha detto bene buttiamo là
dentro era bello il tiro pole il retro e
vai fanno anche secolo amor sesto regata
essi come mai questa politica piano
leggermente 2000 è docente può dire che
se la teniamo così per sei secondi per
te quali c'è giusto umiliazione finale
cosa non basta che è bello ha segnato
pure tu vuo fa tutto sarà ok mi sono
sudata questa partita va bene ragazzi
dire che possiamo concludere qui raga è
stato bellissimo di gran successo viene
fra le parti comitato sì esatto passate
anche dal suo canale che trovate
un'altra partita di altre parti
dell'europa click e senza fischiare ci
vediamo ti sorrido
[Musica]